good afternoon and welcome to cloud on
air live webinars from Google cloud
we're hosting webinars every Tuesday my
name is Shane glass with me today is
injured whippy and today we will be
talking about the visualize 2030
challenge you can ask questions at any
time on the platform and we have
Googlers standing by to add to them
let's get started so I will say with an
ode first it's a little different than
my last live experience which was a 2010
baseball game I was broadcasting so okay
imagine the story will be a little
different so we're talking about the
visualize 2030 challenge today it's it's
a data-driven story to talk about how at
least two of the UN sustainable
development goals influence each other
and one actions might be taken in order
to reach the goals set out in 2030 let's
learn more about the challenge we
encourage you to visit the link here on
the site on this on the page and I think
it's really important that we call out
here that you know this this is a real
opportunity for for students that are
eligible for the contest University
students to have a great impact on the
improvement of the world around them so
the visualize 2030 challenge has done in
collaboration with the World Bank the
United Nations Foundation and the the
global partnership for sustainable
development we're collaborating with
them because it just gives us such a
broader reach and Andrew I think we'd
love to hear your perspective yeah so
that sounds like my cue yeah so I'm a
data scientist and development data
group at the World Bank and for people
who don't know the World Bank we're a
multilateral institution with about 189
member countries I think and we work in
the realm of financing and technical
assistance for four countries mostly low
and middle income countries to help them
on development projects so things like
you know improving your health system or
building new roads or maybe expanding
sanitation or electricity networks stuff
like that but we also work on collecting
and publishing data about development
and I guess that's that's my role in the
organization that's why I'm here talking
to you today so if you if you kind of
sleep on to the next slide I can talk a
little bit about the the United Nations
sustainable development goals which is
the focus of the challenge
the story of these is kind of
interesting to talk about this week
because at the moment not not far from
where we're standing here in New York
the United Nations General Assembly is
meeting oh my and they did the same
thing as I do every year it's ending in
2015 as it turns out on this exact date
and they passed this resolution
committing to these 17 goals for
sustainable development to take place
over the period up to in general twenty
twenty thirty is the target date for
these goals and and you can already see
from the screen it's quite a broad set
of things that they're working towards
but I'll read a couple of that in four
because I think it gives you some sense
of the ambition right you can't really
tell from the the little picture formed
so goal one is to end poverty in all its
forms everywhere goal four is to ensure
inclusive and equitable quality
education and promote lifelong learning
opportunities for all goal five is to
achieve gender equality and empower all
women and girls goal ten is to reduce
inequality within and among countries
goal 14 is to conserve and sustainable
use the oceans seas and marine resources
for sustainable development so it's not
just about people it's about the earth
environment as well and goal 16 is to
promote peaceful and inclusive societies
provide access to justice for all and to
build accountable institutions at all
levels so yeah it's a it's a very broad
spread of goals and there's kind of some
history of this that's worth worth kind
of keeping in mind which is it was a
previous set of goals the Millennium
Development Goals that was kind of
agreed on about 2000 and then carried
through to the 2015 point in time and so
this set of goals is really kind of
replacing a previous set of targets um
you know many of which were achieved and
some which were not um in that period
but like I said these are mostly mostly
setting goals to be achieved by 2030 and
the thing I think you when you listen to
them as I read the line when you look at
them on the screen here they're kind of
big lofty general ideals and orange
ambition right I mean they're not things
that you can necessarily easily measure
they're they're kind of a little bit
abstract and so there's a kind of
framework under these um to make that a
bit more measurable to make this thing
really work which is that under these
seventeen goals there are 169 targets
and I won't read all of them or even a
selection but they're more detailed more
specific things that you can kind of
look at and say yes that was achieved oh
no that wasn't
by the time we reach 2030 and then
underneath those targets each of them
has sort of usually between one or three
indicators and that's where you really
get down to you know the rubber hits the
road you get down to these concrete
outcomes that can be measured and I can
kind of give you some some real examples
of those that might make a little bit I
think I'm a bit clearer so so like I
said the first goal is to end poverty in
all its forms everywhere and that has a
number of targets associated with it the
first of those targets is called target
1.1 the very numerical order to these
things and that is by 2030 eradicate
extreme poverty for all people
everywhere
currently measured it as people living
below a dollar 25 a day and that dog 25
is a kind of international poverty line
that you know is really a term to time
it's actually moved since then sorry but
that target then has an indicator
associated with it and so that's what
you'll find in a data set and that
indicator is the proportion of the
population below the International
poverty line by sex age employment
status and geographic location that is
kind of where people live in an urban a
rural area and so that's the structure
of how you get from these these these
lofty ambitious goals down to something
that we can actually take in and
visualize and talk about in concrete
terms so yeah that's the first thing
these things have to be measurable right
and then that the second thing that that
you might have kind of picked up from
what I was talking about is that whereas
the previous set of goals we had the
Millennium Development Goals it was very
much about kind of country averages it
was a very broad brush approach to
looking at this stuff short one of the
emphases in the SDGs the sustainable
development goals is to be able to
disaggregate that and to look within
countries so I'm you know in that
indicator for poverty that I read out
you could see it was broken down by sex
and by age about employment status and
urban rural locations so you're you're
really looking at subpopulations within
countries and making sure as the kind of
STD mantra goes that nobody is left
behind that everybody is capturing these
datasets um so that's that's the brief
intro to the SD Jay's sure and so just
to summarize that you know we're at the
at the high level you know you have the
end poverty right and when you dig down
into the indicator that's truly kind of
your measurable way of saying here's
where we're making here's how are we
getting addresses where we're making
progress exactly in principle you should
be able to take a country and take a
point in time and attach a number that
indicates a you know the poby right in
whatever Malawi in 2018 is this number
God so that's that
okay that makes sense yeah so then the
next question I guess for me is why am I
here why am I not at my desk well Bank
why am I at Google talking about this
contest and I think that that comes down
to this slide which is that that data
has power right and it hasn't always
been accessible so thinking about how it
hasn't been accessible and this is a
kind of a miracle for an away from from
the World Bank that up until fairly
recently and certainly in the
pre-internet era if you already get hold
of our data such as it is you would send
us a check for about three hundred
dollars and we would send you back a
physical disk and you know that works
fine for sort of libraries and
universities and stuff but it obviously
meant that a lot of people around the
world didn't have access to this day
there right and especially people from
low-income backgrounds the people who
were most trying to help this data was
completely inaccessible so so in about
2010 the World Bank really swung behind
the open data movement and so now all I
do is online it's it's free as long as
there's no kind of privacy restrictions
stopping as publisher that's nothing is
available to everybody and that's kind
of where where this contest comes all
right this is another way of us
promoting our data to get again getting
it out to people getting people to use
it and I think why that's kind of
important I can give an example of a
World Bank or like project that's based
around data which is this thing called
doing business and what they do is they
go from country to country and they just
collect information about how easy it is
to operate a business in that country so
how much tape paperwork does it take to
start a company or how long does it take
to to get an electricity connection set
our power is use it to resolve legal
disputes those sorts of things that are
kinda like day-to-day work for a
business and this dis prejudice may go
over a number of years and all they
really do is publish this data they
publish rankings of countries and so on
but the effect that it has is quite
large because citizens businesses
journalists in countries will look and
say well our country is falling behind
these other neighboring countries who
are better on this measure or this other
measure and so that can kind of promote
a sort of responsiveness of government
to try and fix some of these problems
and I mean it's not just about these
kind of business measures the same thing
happens with with sort of measures of
life expectancy your way um we
originally and some high income
countries maternal mortality has been
sort of getting worse rather than
getting better and you know there's been
a lot of great journalistic work done
taking this kind of public
we'll do that and then writing about it
and then citizens can pick that issue
and try and do something about it
so it's in a lot of ways which are what
I'm hearing you say is that it's it's a
means of accountability for for whether
it's governments or non-government
organizations absolutely very body yeah
exactly
um and so that's part of it is is really
bringing about change the other side to
it that I think is important and we
sometimes forget about is just the value
in in sort of individual citizens of
countries understanding what other
people in the world lives are like how
they live um so I don't know if you're
familiar with Hans Rosling who's a the
later house or thing I think it was a
great data visualization that was deadly
communicator and if you haven't seen his
stuff you should get on YouTube after
this session and look him up but one of
the points he consistently made was that
even the best informed people I mean
maybe people like ourselves about some
of these issues we still know very
little about other countries so people
will still routinely misjudge what the
poverty rate is in a certain country or
you know the the unemployment rate in
other places stuff like that so it's
valuable just to have access to these
data and people be able to see it and
understand the world better yeah they're
not a key point there of accessibility
and that's where I come in so you know I
as our viewers saw earlier so I I
managed the Google cloud public data set
program and in public data sets and open
data in general is something that it's
always been kind of near and dear to my
heart as I you know worked on my
Master's I I would spend ten twelve
hours a week searching for datasets
looking for datasets trying to find
something anything that I could use to
work with and and that's kind of how I
became passionate about this but what I
found over time is is a few things with
public datasets one is that we'll never
truly understand we could be the leading
subject matter experts and the data will
never truly imagine all the possible
legitimate use cases of this data so I'm
making it open and accessible you open
up to a whole new world of innovation
and new ideas that you might not have
had in the past but the other thing is
and you talked about this earlier you
know there there is legitimate costs
associated with creating discs and
shipping discs but if we can host it out
in this case on GCP and make it easier
people get to people can become we can
become a little smarter we can become a
little better and we can become a little
bit a little bit more
for the world around us so you know I
think that's kind of where we've kind of
collaborated together is you know
hosting this data in bigquery and just
making it so much easier for people to
get to in two years yeah absolutely well
I mean we're happy to see our data
spread as far and as wide as it can be
absolutely and that's our goal too right
so I mentioned the the cloud public data
set program just to give you a little
overview on that so we manage we work
with public data providers like the
World Bank like the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration NOAA among
others to host valuable datasets or
copies of their valuable data sets in
GCP so that users can find them discover
them and utilize them much more quickly
and what we found is that that that
removes a level of friction or a barrier
to entry that keep people from utilizing
data and from doing great things in the
first place
I talked a little bit earlier about
bigquery of more than 100 data sets
available bigquery just just passed 100
data sets and just passed a hundred
petabytes of data scanned in the three
years of the program through the ranks
we're really excited about that but it's
not all structured data we do have about
seven petabytes of data in Google Cloud
storage most of that is is satellite
imagery so from things like the USGS
Landsat from from meteorological
satellites as well so certainly a lot of
things out there that they can unlock
the imagination in some ways and can
help whether it's the University student
like is like those eligible for this
contest or if it's a startup that wants
to experiment on this but needs access
to the data do so that they can do so I
think much faster of course all of our
data can be visualized in data studio
which is what we're going to focus on
today for those of you that aren't
familiar data studios are free visual
analytics product they can connect the
data directly from bigquery from the
user interface or from other directions
whether it's the big bigquery data
connector in data studio or if it's even
through Google shapes so certainly a lot
of options there as well and don't worry
we are gonna play with data studio today
and so we're just a real quick overview
and you know where can we find these
data sets where can we learn a little
bit more about
I encourage our users and our viewers to
go on to GCP marketplace where you can
see on the left-hand side there's a list
of datasets there and that will give you
kind of a high-level overview of the
datasets some information about the
source something like where it came from
and who's the provider of it as well as
some sample queries and some sample
demonstrations they help you get started
as quickly as possible ok so this is the
fun part so Andrew can you tell us a
little bit about the world data
indicators yeah there was well
development indicators yeah so um I I
can for certain structured data right
it's not it's not huge it's not
petabytes like the satellite data might
be it's a it's a in storage size its
terms it's a fairly small structured
data set um
but in terms of development indicators
it's relatively large so um this has
been going it's produced my by the group
that I work in at the bank and it's been
going for maybe 40 years now I think and
it's it's kind of structure as a cube so
you have about 1500 development
indicators on different topics from you
know health and education and poverty
and government spending and all kinds of
things like that by about 200 countries
plus or minus and by about up to 60
years so the earliest data we have
generally is about 1960 that the
collection begins and then some datasets
start later than that because it wasn't
collected back then
sure and I mean I should say also this
is this is available in lots of ways not
just through through your platforms
online so people can go to our website
and you can you can access it directly
you can download a bulk CFE download if
you just want the whole thing in one go
on your computer or you can access an
API that we have to be able to use it
programmatically or through our or
Python or more kind of tools like that
and so you might be wondering kind of
one of the connection between this data
and the sustainable sustainable
development goals that I talked about
earlier and if you were listening really
carefully you might have heard me say
well there are 1500 indicators in this
and the SDGs had about 300 indicators
underneath those goals so so one thing
obviously is this is a much more
comprehensive data set and that's that's
probably just cuz it's been around for a
while until it kind of collected a lot
of different indicators over time but
also it's it's supposed to be more
comprehensive it's supposed to where's
the SDGs everything is supposed to kind
of relate to a target and this is kind
of very structured way of thinking about
data
wdi is much more a way of just kind of
in a world and understanding how other
countries looking in development
measures so to kind of give you give an
example of things that you might find in
here that don't directly connect it a
few years but might still be interesting
you'll find something like life
expectancy in here right and there's no
SDG target on life expectancy but what
what there isn't in the STG goals is a
target for instance three point three
which is on the reducing the burden of
hiv/aids and so if you're trying to
think about that it might be useful to
actually understand the context of
likely life expectancy in different
countries to make sense of that and I I
think we may see an example of that
later on spoiler alert we will spoiler
alert but another example of that we
population right so there's no
population targets for either the world
over countries in their sustainable
development goals but there is for
instance a target around improving
housing and upgrading slums but
obviously that's intimately related to
population so it's useful to have these
other indicators alongside that the kind
of ftg indicators to be able to sort of
make sense the world and tell a better
story I think and having that historical
context helps you understand okay you
know we we had the Millennium the
Millennial Development Goals and now we
had the the sustainable development
goals exactly but helps you understand
how you got you know how did we get
where we are today and what's been done
in the past that maybe has or has not
worked and helps to kind of better
understand how to tell its story and
what's truly happening in the world yeah
exactly exactly and that the data lines
get reflects that right you can you know
when I say this data forty years ago it
didn't start with 1500 indicators 40s I
thought it was too probably and it's
grown since um and that the last thing I
should say about wdi is it's not um you
know I'm sitting here talking about what
standing and talking about it but it's
it's not just the World Bank's work so
we we collect data from a lot of
partners from UN agencies from from
country governments from private
companies and and they really deserve
the credit for collecting the data we
just kind of collate it and make it more
easily available so it's it's truly as
an effort then from the the global
community to come you know it is yeah
and then uniting on your platform is an
extension of that to make it even more
available excellent alright well let's
let's dig into the data here a little
bit and let's think into some of the
visualizations so we'll start here this
is a kind of basic visualization I put
together that demonstrates I believe
it's sustainable development goal eight
point sustainable development goal eight
indicator eight point one point one
which looks at
the percentage of the population in a
given country that have access to
electricity and so you'll see the heat
map up here on the top of the color by
countries I sometimes jokingly refer to
it it kind of identifies where as the
red is a a larger percentage of the
population has access to electricity the
deep red where as that blue that really
stands out in sub-saharan Africa
especially has has a significantly lower
percentage of the population with access
to electricity and you can see called
out there at the bottom of the the
fifteen or twenty countries with with
the lowest percentage of the total
population and I think this is a great
example of what you talked about earlier
about how the the different indicators
break down because this is so this is a
point one point one this looks at the
total population but that eight point
one point two looks at rural populations
and eight point one point three looks at
the urban population with with access to
electricity so I think this is a great
example in just kind of very high-level
overview of what's possible with data
studio right and so let's let's kind of
dig into you you have some examples and
I yeah exactly show them side by side
yeah I think so they yeah I think
that'll work ok yeah so this is this is
an example of a visualization that we we
made earlier in the year and it comes
from actually a print publication the
atlas of the sustainable development
goals um so it was kind of made as a
book you can find a PDF and there's also
an online version that you should have
to find pretty easily but but the point
of that publication was really try and
tell these through data stories that
we're looking at this in this contest
um in our in particular way so this one
is you know you're looking at here a map
of the world obviously and it's a
choropleth map it's the kind of map
where each color each country is colored
a different kind of intensity to show a
number for that country and what it's
showing is this measure of air pollution
called PM 2.5 and PM 2.5 relates to
target I think 11.6 which is talking
about the environment environmental
quality in cities and PM people if I was
important because it's a it's a very
small size of particle it's smaller than
than 130th the size of the human hair
and it's the kind of thing you can
inhale and it kind of Lodge deeply in
your lungs and then it can cause disease
so so high levels of PM 2.5 are bad and
there's a there's a World Health
Organization recommendation for the
maximum
suppose you should face so so one of the
things I think that this this raises the
questions readiness for me that's worth
thinking about is is the kind of you
have to be careful around some of these
indicators right so with the wdi data
set as you've loaded it up people can
find the metadata there and that'll tell
you something about how it was created
so so in this case this is actually
measuring that that PM 2.5 measure
across the country but then population
waking it so it kind of reflects the the
average exposure that a person in that
country might have and that's actually
slightly different to what the the SDG
target is looking at which is people in
cities particularly rather than people
across across the entire country or
across the world and you know maybe only
half of people live in cities so so in a
sense you know this is an interesting
visualization but it's important to bear
those those differences from the yet to
do target in mind but I think you have a
version of this as well right yeah until
before we step onto that so PM 2.5
typically comes from burning things so
whether it's fuel whether it's for
cooking for electricity but you know I
think some of the areas highlighted here
could be could also be seeing this come
from from natural sources as well yeah
that's right so I mean we you know I'm
not an expert in almost any of these
specific targets but mormont we produced
this book to try and look at the
different areas and so one of the
interesting things is to dig into that
metadata and say well actually what is
this measuring and it turns out the PM
2.5 also mentions a lot of kind of wind
blow and sound so if you have a city in
the middle of a desert you may have high
levels of PM 2.5 and it's not it's not
air pollution like we would think of
factories and cars right it's kind of
natural pollution and yet it's still
measured by this so that's that's like
another reason that people really should
look at the metadata of things
individualizing yeah so we'll flip over
to the data studio version of this I've
very creatively copy and pasted a lot of
the text that was on the the world the
World Bank's version of this but I think
one thing that's also real interesting
is is you kind of tend to see that
cluster right these these kind of
countries that see this the biggest
impact from this tend to be clustered
together and that's important because
you know air pollution doesn't obey the
laws of political boundaries and so it's
important as we mentioned earlier for
this global effort this global community
to come together to work on this but you
know we talked about the the text that's
on here and I think that's you know we
kind of went back and forth or
about whether you know you know you
mentioned the World Bank and given a lot
of thoughts of this and I actually think
it's a really great way for the World
Bank I think one of the most valuable
things that the World Bank brings to the
table here is not just the curation and
the data that's obviously valuable but
that expertise and that understanding of
the data as well yeah sorry
interesting that the publication that
I've opened this came from is entirely
data storage if you like it's entirely
visualizations there's no kind of
paragraphs of text and that was not
something that was hard for us to adjust
to because we're like well we we need to
include these caveats and these
explanations and we would normally spend
a page we're adding about right but
somehow we need to fit these into you
know two sentences that fit somewhere on
a chart so that was a kind of missing
experience for us but I think it I think
it becomes a really powerful way then
simply but at the same time kind of
richly explaining a story yeah okay so I
can sit here and explain exactly what
you just explained on the last one but I
think we all rather dig into the how
it's made on that yeah I'm curious to
see okay let's take a look so what we're
looking at here now is kind of the the
dashboard the view yeah so you can show
us with anybody anyone as long as you
set the the share settings properly can
can view this from their web browser
using the share button I've got
highlighted here with the mouse but I
think the more fun part is to go into
the edit mode so we've got this pulled
up and this gives you a really nice look
at what you'll see when you first enter
data studio and when you first don't
work in the data so I'll call this out
just ahead of time here a lot of this
text is is manually input I may or may
not have run out of time to do it
another way but so you'll notice they
might not scale probably the way it
would be ideal but let's take a look at
its some of the features of data studio
that have helped us create this
visualization here so I'll select this
this this Geographic map that we've
created here and you'll see it pops up a
list of your available fields here on
the right side and a list of the
dimensions and the metrics you're
measuring here so let's dig into how we
can how we can add data sources and then
how we can how we can begin to work with
them for the analysis so what you'll see
here is the the data source already
loaded up if I click add a data source
it takes me out to the whole list of
connectors there's 28 or 20 some on
Google connect
there's more partner connectors out here
for the purposes of this contest I do
want to use the the datasets that are
available through the website that we
mentioned earlier the cloud.google.com
backslash visualize 2030 so we'll skip
out of this for now I think this is
probably less exciting for the viewers
than them playing around the data but if
we go into our resource tab again now we
can look at blending datasets so this
allows us to bring together both the
World Bank's datasets and the UN
datasets so we don't have the we have
just the UN dataset loaded up in this
particular visualization but if I wanted
to come in here and blend this data what
I would do is it's it's a kind of a
visualization of a joint in sequel right
where I would I would add another data
source and I would say let's take
something I was working with earlier so
the World Bank for instance I hear those
guys do good stuff so we'll add that to
my report and then you can see it gives
me an excuse me a list of the fields
here and I can give a comment join field
between the two in this case I would
probably use countries country name and
and geo area name but we'll set this
aside for now as well so we can dig into
some of the other features and yes I'm
very sure I want to discover those
changes okay so the one last thing we
want to dig into and you can see down
here it's it's on a scale of one to four
which is very different than what the
World Bank's visualization was and what
I've done there is I just created a
custom bin for our users to be able to
go in and say you know once I've created
a copy of this data set that we've made
available and that's important because
it allows users to edit the data to
create their own fields to create
calculated fields and it allows me to
create the custom bins like these using
match statements or case statements so
that our users can more clearly
visualize things it can get a little
cluttered right when you have a map like
this that has a hundred different colors
on it so I think you know I think the
World Bank took a great approach to that
of really narrowing that down to kind of
the four key areas to create these these
areas that stand out Andrea if I were to
ask you what what do you see that stands
out in this map yeah I mean I like you
say that the clustering of dark areas I
think is kind of jumps out most
most immediately yeah and so we were
trading favorite data visualization
professors earlier and you know mind
being Stephen few who talks about kind
of the hierarchy of a visual information
a human brain interprets at color being
at or near the top besides I think
because it's probably ahead of that but
you know this very deep red kind of
stands out against the contrast of that
white background and so you know we can
see kind of what the for lack of a
better term the problem is all right
there is we want to focus all right and
that allows you to kind of call out this
these areas whether it's in Africa it's
in South West soon in Southeast Asia and
I think that really clearly helps you
identify at the beginning of a trend in
the beginning of a story so we've you
know kind of dug through some of these
features in data studio I think one
thing that I really enjoy about data
studio is the ability to drill down at
the continent level so if we take this
and we say oh gosh you know what what's
happening in in Africa is really
standing out to me I can drill down to
Africa so what I really like is you
stole the context of the rest of the
globe around it but you it allows you to
get a closer look at what each of these
countries see and so we'll go back to
our view here for a moment and now you
can go over and highlight and say what's
the actual value in inches countries
here because their bandwidth probably
less exciting we'll take a look at a
more exciting one later but it allows
you to truly get an understanding of of
what's happening in that country at a
very granular level you know I mean
Stingley they're you know the reason
we've been did is because we were one of
the outputs was a print publication
right and it's very hard to tell twelve
shades of red yeah at least at the Pring
quality we can afford but on screen I
imagine you could you could probably get
away not bidding it and just having the
full range of values and then you'd be
able to see that and that kind of talks
to what we the first visualization we
saw the access to exactly as well and
one of the fun things here as well as
we've we've put in a filter for for a
year and so it's allows this viewer to
go down and say you know what hey let's
look at let's look at just 2014 for
instance so allows me to come down here
and select 2014 I've got the set to
single select and it looks like we might
not have data for that year but so I've
got the set of single select so only
show me a single year but if I if I had
set it to just like multiple years I can
show
an average or I could show the some of
that those values over time as well so I
think that's another really great
demonstration of you know hey what is
what are we truly seeing here and what
is our what's our story here right
telling you know one visualization does
not a story make but it can tell you the
beginning of the story right and you can
string these together to tell the true
story of whether it's looking at the
historical context of using you know the
data going back 40 or 50 years or
whether it's what the situation on the
ground is today okay so let's look at
another one one yeah so this is this is
another realization taken from our atlas
of sustainable development goals and
this one's kind of interesting because
it's kind of an unusual kind of it's
only the familiar issues so um so this
is this is relating to target three
point three which includes ending the
AIDS epidemic but rather than taking an
indicator on on hiv/aids particularly
like the prevalence rate for instance
right um what we're looking at here is
life expectancy so just to sort of
quickly understand what you're looking
at each line represents the history of
life expectancy in a particular country
and we've kind of used color to sort of
put all the countries on there in a way
that hopefully isn't too overwhelming
but um what's the first thing that jumps
out at you from from looking at that so
I'm kind of looking at the holistic
pattern of everything moving you know
kind of up into the right which is good
news right yeah exactly right so so I
think that's that's exactly right one of
the things we want people to see is that
well you know you can like it look on
the left hand end and the the lowest
life expectancy that a country had in
1960 was twenty eight which is you know
pretty young adage yeah for life
expectancy by 2016 that's now up to 51
the lowest country in the data set so
there's kind of a general improvement
across time but I said that this was a
data visualization about hiv/aids right
and so you know now we cannot dig in and
say well why is that what we're showing
and so what we've done here we've we've
highlighted in yellow the countries in
sub-saharan Africa and that's that's the
continent the the World Bank region that
was most affected by it will has been
most affected by AIDS but then on top of
that we've also highlighted a slightly
sort of thicker line there that kind of
bold yellow countries countries that had
the highest prevalence of hiv/aids over
that period
and ten countries highlighted there
maybe and what you kind of see from that
is that those countries you know the
life infancy was increasing in line with
all the other countries but then
sometime around the sort of mid 90s
through to the mid 2000 they've actually
been decreasing and that's that's kind
of a I find that fascinating because
it's it's a reflection of this this you
know awful epidemic in terms of kind of
dry demographic data that you might you
might not otherwise look at that way
right and on the plus side you can see
that from about the mid-2000s onwards
these life expectancy lines start to
take up again as you know treatment gets
better as prevention those new better as
awareness increases you know it looks
like they're able to recover most of
that loss that they saw in that in the
late night yeah yeah maybe all right
maybe yeah so I think you know we'll
flip over to the data studio version and
that's a great way and we talked earlier
about taking it at a very granular level
to these data and you can see now I've
chosen to go with obscurity by color to
kind of move the context behind it but
using size we talked about really about
size being such a big hierarchal
importance for how your brain interprets
these visualizations and I've chosen to
call out to countries in particular one
being Rwanda and the other being Zambia
by using the size of my increasing the
thickness these lines and you can see
the exact same pattern here now what's
really interesting about this is you can
mouse over this and you can see hey here
is exactly what the data was at a given
point so if I come back to for instance
1997 like we called out okay I can see
you know the the Zambian life expectancy
of 43 years but if I come out here to to
2016 or 2015 it's back up to 61 we're
you know kind of where was closer or
maybe even above where it was in in 1977
at 51 you know and so I think this is
another great way that and some of the
features in data studio can help help
the students out there participating in
this challenge really understand what's
happening here and really show what's
happening here yeah yeah I mean we've
we've you know we've explored lots of
different sort of interactive tools and
we haven't we haven't really done an
awful lot of that stuff but it you know
it is it's a limitation of what we've
done in terms of static visualizations
that you can't see an image of the data
points you get general trend right
exactly and that's one thing I like
about the
the interactivity of this is is that
ability to really kind of to again
uncover that story that you're gonna
tell you know this is now I think the
World Bank again we talked about adding
context with text on here earlier I
think the World Bank is not a
fascinatingly a great job of this you
know of adding this context in here but
nor our users aren't gonna have this
context when they begin to visualize and
so they you know I like that there's the
ability to call this out and to very
clearly say hey we can discover our own
context in here yeah I mean I think I
was I was telling you before that I
suspect when we first produced the a
version of this chart we we just graph
those life expectancies and and we
actually noticed the pattern of
reactions and then you kind of look at
that and say well some countries are
doing something different from the
general increase everyone else is doing
right you probe into it and you can
pretty quickly come up with the
explanation and that's that's the kind
of roundabout way by which we we would
have gotten to it I think yeah as a data
analyst you know I look at that and I
say what's interesting to me yeah is
what's different right I mean that's
really what calls out to me is you know
okay the general pattern move over to
the right is great news and is important
and should be examined but really
digging into telling that story is
what's what's different and what stands
out and what's the cause of that that's
you know one thing that's really
exciting for me we we talked a lot about
kind of using data studio last night I
think one thing I forgot to call out is
this ability to set the size of of the
dashboard upfront now you can set
multiple pages I only have one for
visualization here so don't feel the
need to create a massive oversized
single page but one thing I really like
in visualization is that ability to use
the limitations of your screen size to
your advantage of creating something the
user has to scroll down to discover I
think it helps the storyteller kind of
communicate the message but controlled
manner right kind of step users the room
in a way that they want to see it and so
I you know one thing that might be
really intriguing is looking at a width
of you know I currently have it set to
what I think would be most convenient
for our users on the webinar today but
setting this you know maybe set the
width a little more narrow and setting
the heights of 10,000 pixels and really
let the viewer scroll through and go
through that discovery journey with you
we'll jump back to the slides here and I
think I think what we see in here answer
is a really great demonstration of
what's possible and how to get started
here in data studio and how you can take
the WDIA
data set and and really just dig into it
and explore and uncover stuff that maybe
no one's ever seen before and that that
to me is really exciting you know
especially for students that are
interested in having an impact and
improving the world around them right I
think we've you know barely scraped the
surface of the data within there and
then I write you know I think you have
some other data sets as well where the
people can come look at and kind of
combine to do these realization so so
hopefully people find some interesting
things I think they will absolutely so
you know we talked a lot about telling
the story today I think that that
narrative kind of came up a lot you know
I think what we want students to do here
is tell your friends folks if you're if
you are a student dig in have fun
visualizing the data set I use the
hashtag visualize 2030
check out the website that's here as
well and make a difference who knows
maybe I'll even win $10,000 I don't know
anyone though wouldn't want to win
$10,000 if you're not a student tell
your friends who you are if you're not a
university student tell your friends who
are tell your family that are and let
them know about this opportunity that we
have out there available again the
deadline for this is November 16th so I
think that's coming up a lot faster than
I expected it to given this September is
almost over it feels like September just
started so certainly get out and get
cracking on this and we're looking
forward to seeing what comes through on
this differently all right well that's
it for us folks we're gonna step away
for just a moment here but stay tuned
for a live Q&A Andrew and I look back in
less than a minute
you
okay well welcome back everyone I'm
still here with with Andrew and we've
got some audience questions coming in so
let's dive right into these enjoy I
think this first one is probably for
both of us
but how can they to be made more
accessible to people around the world
yeah I mean I think there's a few
different aspects to that the the
Internet has made it it's just vastly
different as was before that's that's
kind of the big step change but there's
other things we think about to like
licensing issues can be very restrictive
and in preventing people from getting
access to data that otherwise might so
we're always working to try and you know
negotiate better licenses with people we
get data from so you can share it and
then the other thing that I think is
worth bearing in mind too is the number
of people who are you know especially in
lower-income countries who are maybe
accessing the internet from mobile
devices right and so we're always kind
of conscious of you know how long does
it take to load the World Bank webpage
on a mobile device on the kind of
connection you might have in a
developing country and it's it's not
always good it's it's it's great if you
produce the the best website in world
with no one can vote it doesn't exactly
yeah yeah and you you touched on
licensing for me that that's probably
the big one as well one thing I see a
lot of is datasets that are not licensed
at all there's no license attached to
them absolutely and that that can almost
be worse sometimes in a restrictive
license because it'll scare users off
yeah I didn't come in and say I don't
know if I'm gonna get trouble freezing's
data set up let's say if I just want to
use it so you have looking at some of
the open source licenses that are out
there whether it's Apache Creative
Commons MIT whatever one you want to use
attaching that open source license to
your data set up front I think can
really help yeah I understand I mean
we're you know we're as guilty of that
as the next as the next person like we
we used to not do that really well we're
doing it a lot better from now on like
you can usually find World Bank data
sets and the license attached to them
and it's I mean obviously the important
part is making data available right but
yeah the licensing is kind of that next
step yeah especially if you want you
know you maybe want data journalists to
use this in a publication and right
they're gonna care about that a little
bit more than maybe a student would sure
absolutely
so this next one is how can we improve
data collection to ensure representation
and accuracy especially in developing
countries yeah that's I mean that's a
huge difficult issue I think so a lot of
I mean it depends a lot on the the type
of data you're talking at so I mean we
talked a little bit about poverty data
and a lot of that information comes from
like large-scale survey
operations that are pretty expensive to
run and they have world banking and our
partners put a lot of money and effort
into doing um and you know those you
have the advantage that you're kind of
doing a formal survey so you can you can
actually make sure that it's
representative of people in the country
but not all data is like that right a
lot of a lot of data that we use today
is this kind of secondary data that you
kind of have as a side effect of other
things and so that can be much more
difficult to make sure that they're
representative and you can't have these
these two conflicting movements on the
one hand wanting to make sure nobody's
left behind in the data is
representative and on the other hand you
kind of have a lot of like big data so
people are very excited about like what
can we see from I don't know you know
people's people sort of internet usage
or or from like there's been a lot of
work and development on cell phone and
data collecting people who you know
monitoring what kind of patterns you can
see in that data and it can be you know
academically it's really interesting but
it has the downside that you're only
collecting information on people who
have cell phones right in some countries
is a minority of people absolutely
it's not a simple single answer to that
question I don't think it depends a lot
on whether it's coming from them and
what the topic is and so real quick what
are your thoughts on whether it's
representative sampling or or kind of
sub sampling populations to to kind of
keep costs down for those those surveys
you mentioned but but still getting a
potentially representative sample of the
population yeah I mean it's it's gonna
be interesting actually I think um I
mean that's always we're talking before
and I was reading out that that uh the
the poverty indicator and it says you
know population proportion population
below the national poverty line by sex
age employment status and geographic
location well we don't have that now
right now you can go to the World Bank
website and you'll find you'll find
poverty on as not languages for some
large countries that we do that kind of
thing we we're so cleverly or all the
countries are cleverly structure in
those surveys to get a kind of urban
rural breakdown but I don't know
anywhere really where you can get great
data on that broken down by all of those
things right it's going to take I think
a little bit of it's gonna take probably
resources for a certain are more
investment and yeah maybe some clever
technique to get that done and there's a
privacy issue there to your right of
saying you know there's only there is a
moral area there that are
you know not working there yeah yeah I
mean I think the STDs aren't going to
hit that because they're not they're not
just aggregating so much to get down to
like souls of ten people whatever you
know most cases were probably still
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people or tens of thousands of people in
these the kinds of disaggregates that
will be interesting for this purpose but
but yeah I mean that definitely becomes
a problem the more fine-grained you get
absolutely so the third one here from
your perspectives and I think this is
probably your perspective how do you
measure success in data collection
what's a win for you guys and are there
any areas that you prioritize over
others yeah so the second the second is
Eve means stated in the first part in a
way so from the World Bank's perspective
we you know we sort of have a special
responsibility for gold one and ten the
poverty goal and the inequality goal the
the World Bank's role at least in reason
history has been has been to work on
poverty particularly an inequality kind
of comes along with that so particularly
collecting data on those things has
always been a priority within the bank
although as I said were involved in in
other areas as well how do you measure
success in your data collection and
measurement I mean getting good quality
data I getting getting the cleanest data
you can get I think is important because
it's kind of thing I mean in my position
in working on this this data set the
world of all indicators I'm not at the
sort of collection stage of the day
right we generally taking this data from
other people who've already collected it
and one thing you can't tend to fix you
know areas in the data once they've
reached that point so collecting data
you know at the point of collection
making sure things are as clean as
possible is is I think one measure of
successful data collection and there's a
lot of technologies that help with that
right now on you know people are walking
around with tablets and doing interviews
and collecting GPS locations live and
stuff like that whereas in the past that
could have been a lot more affirmed when
you're working with pencil and paper and
stuff like that yeah and especially as
5g source or a lot of internationally I
was over at the very very early edge of
that but you know that having that
improved bandwidth or a mobile capacity
I think will help us well yeah well so I
think I suspect a lot of the places they
click on the poky data that lucky if
they have 3g right yeah absolutely yeah
that's that's certainly again we talked
about that level of investment in
resourcing it's necessary little success
so we'll give you a chance to breathe
I'll take the first half of this go for
it yeah tell me
here you jump in so what makes a good
data story and what difference is there
between a data visualization and an
infographic to me what makes a good data
studio or story rather is is that
ability to walk the user through the
journey of discovery right of saying you
know at this high level whether it's
globally whether it's regionally whether
it's at a Continental level saying okay
here's what the situation looks like but
let's dig in and let's learn either why
or how this kind of got to be and walk
the user through that journey and I
really like that process of people
discovering throughout the process not
giving all the information upfront but
usually in those visualizations out them
understand not only what's happening but
even why or how it's happening in terms
of difference to data visualization an
infographic we were debating this
earlier to me a data visualization is is
a lot like what we looked at earlier
which it's truly designed to communicate
the data behind it or as an infographic
kind of is a little more designed to
tell a narrative or a story in there
tends to use kind of less theta e
elements more designer and tour elements
yeah exactly I mean it's interesting too
when I think about what makes a good
dose story it depends so much on the
medium yeah and sometimes you can choose
the medium you're working in but
sometimes you can't right so the the
Alice that I was showing that the the
visualizations from before that was it's
kind of like a traditional publication
right it was a print publication I wish
I had a copy I could plug right now to
show you but but also you know as a PDF
and then it was kind of online as an
afterthought to that and you end up with
a really different way of telling a
story then if you you start from an
interactive mindset and some of the
stuff you're sitting out of out of
newsrooms now what Interactive's they're
just really mind-blowing amazing because
they because I starting perspective now
they know that they they have a certain
capacity you know so an attention span
from users and stuff like that right I
and we talked earlier about some of our
kind of favorite professors right from
for data visualization other it's Hugh
or Edward Tufte or whomever I encourage
our viewers to go out and really dig
into that well I definitely actively
undated journalists as well right I mean
that is sort of the stuff in your times
neither of those is pretty amazing
pretty impressive yeah so how convenient
olynyk's the applied to social
environmental issues I'll give an
example before I came over to Google I
was working as work
with noah on to make their data very
similar to this more publicly accessible
and usable and what we've found is
they'd produce some weather radar data
it's part of their mission and they have
made the public the data available
publicly is if I want GCP as well as
other sources in the sharing just think
him in a a group of Ornithology so
scientists studying birds came in and
said I can use that data to study bird
migration path rooks and you know but
what's mind-blowing is that to a
meteorologist that's the same that's the
noise in your signal you know but what's
the noise and urologists view an
apologist is the signal in the in the
weather is the noise so again we talked
about you know applying data analytics
to to social environmental issues the
first step is making that data available
for people to use licensing it properly
and then using that to help tell gain
that understanding of the how and why
and what's happening behind it and using
that to kind of communicate and I love
the idea of a data-driven application of
resources we talked about a lot that
resourcing is not infinite and so we're
using data to to make an informed
decision about that I think is really
critical as well yeah definitely I think
you've picked up some of the main things
there so the last one here and I'm
really glad we got this question came in
I forgot to mention it but many fields
in the datasets use abbreviations to
store information where can I find
information regarding those fields along
with the meaning of the abbreviated data
inside them yeah so that's a great
question which I will take since it's
our data that we're talking about today
on so I mean just just to sort of
explain why we do that um it's if you
start to work with country data at any
scale you very quickly realized that
that most countries have many different
names so you know you might have United
States in America you might have United
States might have USA might have America
like all those things in different
datasets might refer to the same country
so so a lot of the times we'll try to
use to anodize conventions where we can
so for instance we include the sort of
iso a three-letter country codes for
countries as well as the name that sort
of the World Bank's understanding an
official name alongside there and so I
actually try to use you know when I'm
doing internal manipulation of data and
you know joining things and filtering
things I like try to use those codes
rather than the country names because I
you know I I don't like the dependency
that you know countries change names
wouldn't even you wouldn't imagine but
uh but you're working this area in
something you realize every few years a
country will actually change its
official name yeah if you tried to join
on desire today you have some trouble
right exactly and that those problems
are still filtering through datasets you
find today so so that's the reason they
exist in the first place to find out
what they refer to aren't so directly I
think as you've loaded up on your
platform there's multiple tables and one
of the you know there'll be a table for
say countries where you'll sort of see
the connection between countries to some
other metadata over the country the same
from from kind of series you'll get more
information about the series itself from
a kind of series table so you can't you
can kind of find that stuff and I guess
you can you can access that through the
platform as well but if you I mean if
you go to our website the world
allotment indicators on the World Bank
website you can fairly easily dig into
that stuff we often have it's it's not
all as obvious as it should be some of
those things are you may have to dig
down a bit and there's a last final
result we also have a data help desk
email address which I wish I knew right
now I don't but if you google World Bank
data help desk I'm sure you'll find the
the page that gives you the email
address and and they're pretty good at
answering those queries um if you know
if you find something you just can't
make sense of yeah and we talked about
blending earlier I think that's another
yeah but you mentioned a great way to
kind of just explore what what some of
that means and whether it makes more
sense for you to have the full name on
your visualization exactly I have you
know some of the abbreviated names as
well yeah I mean through their company
code is great for me but most people
don't find them particularly intuitive
sure no I feel same way about airport
codes there you go yeah okay well that
is it for today tune in next Tuesday for
the next cloud on-air thank you for
watching Thanks
you
[Music]